les métaux politique bonsoir et
bienvenue dans l'hebdo politique votre
rendez vous politique du dimanche soir
sur radio sensations en partenariat avec
tv 78 épisodes 196 notre invité ce soir
et karl olive géopolitique car le livre
on soir bonsoir les colas vous êtes le
maire divers droite de poissy et vice
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines après le temps de l'horreur
vendredi 23 avril à rambouillet avec
l'assassinât d'une fonctionnaire de
police est venue cette semaine le temps
d hommage hommage national notamment ce
vendredi matin à rambouillet présidée
par jean castex stéphanie mon ferme et a
été décoré à ce titre de la légion
d'honneur à titre posthume
jeudi se sont tenues les obsèques de la
victime dans un cadre plus privé cette
fois ci car le livre très vite après l'
attaque est venu le temps des critiques
et des questions dans le débat public et
médiatique comment et pourquoi cet homme
qui est rentré illégalement sur le
territoire a pu être régularisés l'
enquête se poursuit on va pas vous
interrogé là-dessus mais vous à titre
personnel d'aidé vendredi 23 avril vous
étés position vous vous êtes positionnés
sur une forme d'union nationale
visiblement vous n'avez pas été entendu
c'est plutôt l'inversé
comment vous jugez justement tout ce qui
se passe depuis une semaine à ce propos
et puis chacun qui semble tirer la
couverture de son côté
bon d'abord on est toujours dans un état
de sidération par rapport à cet acte
innommable à l'endroit d'une
fonctionnaire de police qui était tout
simplement exceptionnel mais comme le
sont nos forces nos forces de police
oui il me semble que dans de pareilles
situations il faut que nous soyons sur
une concorde nationale sans exclusive et
mesurée et qu'on ait conscience qu'au
quotidien tout tout ce monde-là sauve
nos vies aux dépens des leurs et on l'a
encore vu la semaine dernière
rappelons que dans notre constitution
l'article 3 fait de la sécurité nos
premières
des libertés et on l'oubli et c'est vrai
que moi je ne peux pas me satisfaire que
bien souvent on vienne stigmatiser la
police nationale la police municipale
les gendarmes les militaires alors que à
99,9 pour cent
ces gens là sont des professionnels
engagés et qui veillent encore une fois
sur nos vies au quotidien
qu'est ce que vous pensez des critiques
qui disent que la france est trop
laxiste d'un point de vue migratoire
même dans le camp de la droite
heller votre camp initial même si
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes plus engagés
sheller mais c'est quand même votre
famille politique de base on a entendu
des voix celle de valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile-de-france
faire le lien entre immigration et et
terrorisme qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cela vous faut que nous soyons très
humble dans la lecture que nous devons
avoir et que chacun puisse balayer
devant sa porte
j'aurais aimé typiquement que la gauche
puisse affirmer son soutien plein et
entier
j'aurais aimé tout simplement entendre
les verts qui sont plus à regarder
comment on va préparer les vélos des
policiers municipaux à la place de leurs
voitures
j'aurais aimé que les élèves puissent
aussi faire amende honorable il ya dix
mille policiers qui ont été supprimés au
moment où l air était était aux affaires
j'aurais aimé aussi que l'extrême droite
ne se saisissent pas moins de dix
minutes après l'attentât de cette cause
nationale pour en faire une basse
opération politicienne
aujourd'hui je pense que il faut
vraiment qu'on prenne ce sujet plus que
jamais à bras le corps et un problème
selon vous tout de même nous soyons sans
état d'âme nous soyons sans état d'âme
pour celles et ceux alors ils sont pas
forcément très nombreux qui sont souvent
des islamistes radicaux qui viennent
blues il paie et qui n'ont d'autres
desseins le sns que de venir faire
trembler la république la république de
rester debout il ne faut pas tremblé ce
que la république est trop laxiste parce
que c'est un peu le sujet qu'on entend
on sait aussi que l'extrême droite même
si c'est une affaire politicienne pour
elle d'après d'après vous c'est aussi et
qui se fait entendre sur sur ce sujet là
plus que plus que les hôtesses qu'elle a
raison de poser ce diagnostic d'un
laxisme avec des populations qui ne
devrait pas être sur le territoire
normalement je dis encore une fois que
lorsqu'on on pose le diagnostic
évidemment que quand quelqu'un qui n'est
pas dans les radars en arrive comme ceux
tunisien radicaliser à de tels actes on
peut se poser la question sur qu'est-ce
qui n'a pas fonctionné
est ce qu'il aurait dû être régularisés
est-ce que lorsqu'il est arrivé il y a
dix ans en france de manière illégale
il n'aurait pas fallu le prendre un tout
petit peu plus d'an encore une fois dans
le curseur de ces radars force est de
constater qu'il ya quelque chose qui n'a
pas abouti
là je me satisfais qui viennent une loi
sur l'éthique est présenté mercredi est
terminée mais mercredi c'est la
surveillance numérique notamment
oui mais c'est un c'est un début c'est
un début encore une fois je pense qu'il
faut que nous soyons très humble et que
est ce que vous vous me rende lions pas
voilà que nous ne tremble illon pas et
ça c'est important
nicolas parce que on a à faire dans nos
collectivités
regardez ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières années conflans à l'endroit
d'un enseignant le savoir des lumières
magnanville déjà des églises est très
touché un parraineur bouyer alors là on
a trois collectivités conflent
magnanville rambouillet qui sont des
collectivités très paisible est
exceptionnel justement en lien avec cinq
arrivées ce qu'il faut dire aussi à ceux
qui nous écoutent qui nous regardent aux
français en général
écoutez même si on peut faire tout notre
possible on ne pourra jamais éviter le
risque zéro on pourra jamais réussir à
arriver au risque 0 0% à 0 attaques y
aura toujours forcément un déséquilibré
il faut faire avec un peu comme on dit
aux gens vivaient avec le virus il faut
aussi vivre avec ce risque là il faut et
ce qu'il faut tenir ce discours de
vérité la preuve le commissariat de
rambouillet avait été rénovée avec des
sas spécifiquement mis en place pour
lutter contre ça on ne dit pas si le
dynamisme qu'on tende vers
la zéro les héros crime évidemment il
est celle objectif vers lequel on doit
attendre que nous soyons plus ferme
effectivement sur les contrôles de
migration oui mais moi je ne suis pas
pour stigmatiser pour stigmatiser
en revanche celles et ceux encore une
fois les islamistes radicaux qui ne
viennent que pour abîmer la france
fragilisée la république est donc
vraiment affaiblir les français aucun
état d'âme par rapport à cela
vraiment une main ferme karl olive cette
triste actualité c est entre choqué avec
d'autres bien que différente on y décèle
quand même un lien
à commencer par cette tribune des
généraux qui est paru juste avant cette
attaque horrible c'était le 21 avril sur
le site de valeur actuelle des centaines
de militaires et dénoncent notamment un
délitement de la france ils s'inquiètent
de l'évolution prises par le pays je les
cite parle d'une france en péril et ils
disent que si rien n'est fait une
explosion une intervention de leur
camarade n'est pas à exclure
que dites-vous sur sur le fond d'abord
est ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
d'un délitement progressif du pays vous
êtes souvent positionné sur l'inquiétude
que vous portez à votre ville avec les
années où il ya eu des risques est ce
que vous partagez ce diagnostic sur
l'ensemble du territoire aussi ce que je
constate c'est qu'il ya une espèce de
déliquescence de l'eau de l'autorité
dans le pays et de gérer toute autorité
alors on va vite passer sur l'autorité
familiale on le voit sur les mineurs
certain nombre de mineurs dans les
quartiers populaires parfois les parents
ne démissionne pas mais ils sont
dépassés premièrement une autorité qui
est défaillante parfois aussi dans le
système scolaire
on voit combien de fois on a vu des
mineurs dans les classes se permette de
gifler ou avoir des mêmes des pistolets
sur eux à d'autres époques pardonnez moi
je veux pas l'ancien combattant mais
dans les années 80 ça n'existait pas ça
enfin une autorité effectivement et une
défiance à l'endroit de la police et 2
et de la judiciarisation de notre pays
il me semble qu'il faut absolument
ressac réalisé l'autorité de l'état
quand on touche un policier on touche à
la république quand on touche à un élu
on touche à la république ça ne doit pas
se faire quand on touche un enseignant
c'est toucher aussi à la république et
ça c'est juste pas possible
finalement qu' ils ont pas si tort
sanitaire parce qu'on a beaucoup
caricaturé ce qu'ils avaient dit aussi
beaucoup de gens qui est très choquant
il faut déconnecter il faut déconnecter
la réflexion de fond que l'on peut
partager et la fonction que ni les que
ces militaires incarne il faut les
sanctionner
vous pensez quand les militaires
s'affirme en tant que anciens militaires
ou généraux et que le principe de leur
de leur engagement est justement un
droit de réserve
là il ya il ya un sujet évidemment qui
me dérange j'aurais aimé
j'aurais aimé que puisque ces personnes
là et sur certains points on peut les
rejoindre ont des idées pour faire
avancer ou plutôt reculé les aspects
d'insécurité en france on puisse les
retrouver autour d'une autour d'une
table pour phosphorer avec d'autres
d'autres acteurs voilà et puis
évidemment on en parlait tout à l'heure
nicolas et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
très rapidement le front national en
syrie le sujet pour ramener à ramener à
eux les généraux pour venir au fond qui
est beaucoup plus intéressant et vous
parliez du coup d'une perte d'autorité
qu'irresponsable là dedans est ce que ce
sont les adultes d'aujourd'hui qui n'ont
plus la force pour tenir tenir tête aux
objets nous est ce que c'est c'est la
société en elle-même en fait cette
société aussi très mondialisé qui est
violente et donc les jeunes le sont
aussi aujourd'hui est ce qu'il n'ya pas
aussi un lien avec ça et que ce n'est
pas tant un problème plus français que
allemand qu'américain que chinois ou
japonais
commençons par balayer devant notre
porte on est tous responsables et donc
d'une certaine manière je suis aussi
responsable et je fais en sorte de
prendre avec mes compétences ce que je
peux mettre en place dans ma
collectivité
je crois profondément à la réciprocité
entre les droits et les devoirs
je pense que ça se passe aussi de ceux
de ce point de vue là au départ on ne
peut pas accepter qu'un gamin à 12 ans
en pleine nuit soit
en train de casser un abribus alors
qu'il devrait être avec sa famille donc
il ya l'éducation des parents départ on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui moi je du mal à
accepter que à l'époque ou lorsqu on
rentrait dans une classe les élèves se
se levait que c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui qu'on arrive à en insultes
et les profs on a une autorité aussi qui
est à la portée de l'éducation nationale
et dont elle peut se saisir
je ne peux pas non plus pardonné mois
mais me satisfaire de voir
qu'aujourd'hui les rendez-vous les liens
sociaux et disparus pour inculquer
simplement des valeurs de bonjour au
revoir merci des valeurs de discipline
et de respect des règles si on pouvait
remettre un service national digne de ce
nom en n'évoluant pas celui qu'on a
connu et que j'ai pu connaître moi je
suis là 91,10 comme on dit donc octobre
1988 1990 91 pardon voilà c'est quand
même des choses où on était en sueur un
creuset où la mixité sociale où
l'apprentissage des règles et des
valeurs
on sortait de là on avait grandi
intellectuellement et psychologiquement
et il y avait du black du blanc du
beurre du bistrot du tout aujourd'hui
y'a pas aussi un problème d'ordre social
avec des familles des jeunes qui se
sentent un peu délaissé par la
république dans des quartiers où on sait
que les commerces ferment ya moins de
services publics et qui exprime
peut-être très très malheureusement leur
mal être par la violence par le manque
de respect ce que toujours plus
d'autorité c'est ça qui va régler le
problème est qu'il ya possible questions
sociales
tout est très important des vérités
nicolas tout est une question
d'équilibré
pas plus d'autorité que des deux que que
des dents tout genre
encore une fois oui il faut pas trop je
dire de discipline in fi des c'est quand
même pas le cas aujourd'hui mais là une
manière quand aujourd'hui encore un
intérêt à rester chez soi plutôt que
d'aller travailler
le curseur n'y est pas non plus et sacré
à la fois de l'injustice et je dirais
pardonnez moi l'expression de la justice
sociale est ce que vous êtes inquiet
pour terminer sur ce sujet en lien aussi
avec l'aco vider le déconfinement du
pays est ce que vous êtes inquiet des
tensions sociales dans les quartiers où
on sait aussi que ce sont des familles
les plus pauvres avec la coved qui ont
été impactés par la crise économique et
une tension sociale qui pourrait
remonter et qui s'expriment contre les
policiers très souvent elle est déjà
scellé un poids si elle est déjà monté
depuis depuis un an et on n'est pas un
microclimat dans ce dans ce domaine là
et on voit bien pas seulement dans les
quartiers populaires on voit bien que
les français sont fatigués l'expression
populaire me fais des rôtis et farsi et
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de d'impatience
il ya beaucoup plus parfois de haine
entre les uns et les autres et pas
seulement dans les dans les quartiers
populaires et ça évidemment on peut le
comprendre
une fois qu'on a dit ça il faut bien
qu'on fasse en sorte qu' on puisse s'en
sortir le mieux possible et retrouver
entre guillemets une vie une vie normale
donc évidemment on peut tout entendre et
nous autres qui sommes les chefs de
chantier comme j'aime à dire les
fantassins la république les les maires
de terrain nous sommes des aiguillons
des facilitateurs et on l'a montré
encore au cours des derniers mois pour
être un petit peu inventif alors
inventif c'est quoi typiquement c'est
par exemple proposer des aides aux
familles sans conditions de ressources
pour aller faire du sport pour les faire
de la culture c'est inciter à consommer
local là où aujourd'hui notre économie
est exsangue en donnant des des bons
d'achat pour faire gagner des voitures
on consomme local c'est le cercle
vertueux de l'économie locale savez il
n'ya pas de petites ou de grandes idées
il ya simplement une prise de conscience
que si on veut s'en sortir ça sera pas
contre l'état ça sera pas à côté de
l'état ça sera ensemble et l'expression
fernand vers nation pour moi prend
vraiment toute sa valeur par rapport à
cela
c'est moi le matin je me lève pas en
disant je vais faire une politique de
gauche ou de droite
je me lève le matin en disant est ce que
les décisions que nous allons prendre
vont faciliter le quotidien de nos
administrés c'est ça ma boussole et rien
d'autre vous parliez de
de la vie d'avant de aussi peut-être du
retour des jours aux heureux
quatre étapes ont été annoncés c'est
l'autre grande actualité nationale pour
le déconfinement la première c'est lundi
demain avec fin des restrictions de
déplacement journée en attestation plus
accélération à partir du 19 mai
ouverture des commerces terrasse lieux
culturels enceinte sportive couvre-feu
repousse à 21h09 joint ses 23 heures et
puis fin du couvre-feu notamment le 30
juin ce qu'elles ont déjà ce calendrier
sera soumis aux chiffres de l'épidémie
avec un taux d'incidence qui doit être
en dessous de 400 cas pour 100000
habitants
comment vous vous réagissez à c'est à
ces annonces karl olive on sait aussi
que vous avez l'oreille du président de
la république très souvent qui vient
vous visitez et aussi de vos administrés
qu'avec eux vous distille depuis qu'ils
ont découvert ce nouveau calendrier
d'abord on voit on voit un peu de
lumière au fond du tunnel et ça fait un
an que que malheureusement on vit entre
guillemets dans la pénombre
la deuxième chose c'est que je trouve
que c'est cohérent et c'est cohérent
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
enfin le président est venu à la
rencontre des principaux intéressés
il est venu à poissy il ya un peu plus
d'un mois je l'avais appelé un dimanche
je lui ai proposé de le rencontrer avec
15 maires de toute la france pour
justement pour lui faire remonter sans
filtre je dirais les les sujets et la
réalité du terrain qu'ils passent dans
le sérum de vérité il m'avait dit banco
et deux jours plus tard ou téléphone de
l'elysée pour dire monsieur le président
sera avec vous le mercredi c'est ce qui
s'est passé ce moment là est un moment
de bascule c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est le président la république himself
en dix ans le sujet que j'ai pu avoir à
l'hôpital de poissy et avec les maires
lors de la visioconférence des maires
d'île de france mais également le maire
de la clusaz le maire de roche la
molière dans la loire le maire de toulon
et wathelet dans l'est et le maire de
ploemeur en bretagne a été un moment de
bascule et moi je trouve que c'est
cohérent il est important qu'elles en
aient des territoires en résumé c'est un
peu vous qui avait dicté ce calendrier à
emmanuel macron lui ai simplement dit ce
que je répète souvent et mes administrés
le connaît c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya
pas un sujet qui n'est pas validée par
les principaux acteurs que sont les
habitants même manière les maires sont
les principaux prescripteurs les maires
connaissent mieux que quiconque de
gauche comme de droite leurs administrés
le terrain et donc j'ai suggéré
président je suis pas le seul mais je
suis heureux de voir que en un mois et
demi il eu plus de visio quasiment
quatre ans et ça va continuer et tant
mieux parce que ça permet aussi à ces
gens là de montrer qu'ils sont capables
de renvoyer du terrain vers le sommet
des informations sans filtre alors que
jusqu'à présent le sensation que nous
avions c'était deux choses la première
être mis devant le fait accompli et
deuxièmement qu'on nous impose
effectivement les choses ou qu'on vienne
nous voir simplement quand la course est
terminée alors le taux d'incidence dans
les yvelines au 26 avril et de 367 cas
pour 100000 habitants sur sur 7 jours
glissants donc juste en dessous delà de
la limite 1 annoncée par emmanuel macron
pourrait éventuellement revenir sur ces
sur ces mesures de déconfinement est-ce
que vous pensez que certains disent déjà
et vous savez que c'est le jeu aussi de
critiquer tout ce qui est dit et fait
que c'est trop risqué avec les chiffres
ne sont pas assez bas pour déjà
s'engager à intel déconfinement est ce
que si jamais on se rend compte qu'il ya
un redémarrage de l'épidémie parce que
la vaccination n'avance pas assez vite
que le variant indien se propage alpes
et qu'on pourra re confiné qu'on pourra
dire localement dans les yvelines dont
vous ne pouvez plus elle est allée au
cinéma est ce que c'est possible
aujourd'hui de faire cela tant les
espérances et les promesses sont
aujourd'hui très importante aussi la
teinte très forte ce qui se pa un risque
la politique on peut pas tout attendre
de l'état l'état il n'a pas la boussole
du virus
celle inverse c'est bien le virus qui
guident l'actualité est encore une fois
certainement pas le président la
république où les présidents des grands
partis politiques la porte d'entrée
c'est la porte d'entrée sanitaire donc
la boussole où elle est elle est aux
portes des aussi d'aider des hôpitaux
elle est là la boussole elle aux portes
des hôpitaux et les chiffres que vous
venez de donner nicolas et vous avez
complètement raison n'est après six
mille personnes en réanimation journée
puisque au début du lusc aux démons et
avec des des populations des personnels
hospitaliers auxquels je veux rendre
vraiment hommage qui sont effectivement
sous tension ce qu'on note c'est un
tassement un tassement dans
l'augmentation un tassement dans
l'augmentation donc on peut s'engager
sur un calendrier
alors je dis pas qu'on peut s'engager
sur un calendrier je dis que ça va
plutôt dans le bon sens mais maintenant
il faut que chaque français prennent
conscience de choses le respect des
gestes barrières
le masque doit être portée on doit
respecter les distances physiques et
deuxièmement se faire vacciner se faire
vacciner il n'y a pas cinquante mille
solutions c'est se faire vacciner pour
deux choses même même avec de l'astra
zenica pourtant pour deux choses la
première chose c'est que on va se
rapprocher de plus en plus sur ce qu'on
appelle limogne l'immunité collective et
deuxièmement c'est un moyen de ne pas
contaminer et évidemment son prochain
oui j'ai été vacciné en tant que
président du conseil de surveillance de
l'hôpital de poissy avec de l'astra
zeneca il ya un mois et demi maintenant
ça s'est très bien passé
il ya 3000 agents à l'hôpital
hospitalier intercommunal de poissy et
saint germain 80% a été vacciné par
astrazeneca
il n'y a pas eu de difficulté donc
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent je les
invite à se faire vacciner et pourrait
pour répondre à ces problématiques de
parfois de planning avec de la
vaccination qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
fait parce que des gens annulent les
rendez vous ce qu'il faut élargir
massivement aux plus de 18 ans ou plus
de 30 ans la vaccination
très vite pour justement se rapprocher
de l'immunité collective dont vous
parlez de choses sur le sujet d'abord je
ne suis pas un frondeur
je suis qui prennent des initiatives
visible je considère que nous sommes
dans un état de droit et que c'est
important de le rappeler certains de mes
collègues a priori temps de le faire si
demain quelqu'un de votre âge de 35 ans
ou 40 ans venait à se faire vacciner et
au sortir de la vaccination
malheureusement attraper une embolie
pulmonaire
jean serait le responsable et celles et
ceux qui tiennent la seringue en serait
responsable
également donc il faut qu'on soit très
très vigilants par rapport à cela
en revanche pesé de tout son poids pour
ce que vous venez de dire nicolas
élargir la vaccination au moins de 55
ans ça c'est autre chose et il faut que
nous posions de tout notre poids ça veut
dire a appelé le président de la
république pour le dire ça serait bien
de faire cela faire la démonstration au
président que aujourd'hui il ya une
possibilité avec des doses qui parfois
sont sont pas suffisamment utilisé de
pouvoir proposer au monde enseignant aux
atsem au personnel scolaire aux
policiers et tous les enseignants n'ont
pas 55 ans et plus 1 il ya même très peu
qui aujourd'hui ont plus de plus de 55
ans il aimerait se faire vacciner
il faut que nous élargissions évidemment
à moins de 55 ans et on est capable de
le faire chez maurice est appelé le site
des élections très rapidement ils
n'auraient cinq minutes juste une
question le pass sanitaire pas de débat
ceux qui disent que si une nouvelle
atteinte aux libertés
pour vous ça il faut il faut en laisser
excusez moi mon nez l'espèce humaine qui
est les derniers à avoir deux passes
sanitaire quand vous fait voyager des
animaux il faut bien passer sanitaire
quand vous faites voix voyages et des
plantes il faut aussi un passionné terre
n'y a pas de raison que l'homme n'en est
pas très bien parlons des élections
départementales et régionales qui
arrivant en juin prochain vous serez sur
la liste ensemble pour les yvelines
c'est le nom de la majorité locale
départ rassemblement pour les yvelines
rassemblement pour les yvelines et
excusez moi vous avez aujourd'hui tous
les cantons 1 on l'on peut le résumer
ainsi centre et droite compris
clairement si vous ne faites pas le
grand chelem le 27 juin prochain ça sera
une année chèque pour votre majorité
sûrement pas sûrement pas attendu où on
n'est que des compétiteurs il faut avoir
le respect de l'adversaire quel qu'il
soit mais quand on a 21 sur 21 cantons
fait 20 sur 21 éventuellement ce serait
se dire qu'on a moins bien fait c'est
logique mais quelle déception par contre
je suis absolument pas d'accord et vous
c'est une c'est une compétition une
élection et c'est justement parce qu'il
faut respecter tous les adversaires que
on est sérieux sur le sujet simplement
dire que le département reste le
partenaire de proximité privilégiée de
tous les administrés moi je me présente
sur vous serez candidat oui poissy
achères hr et carrières sous poissy avec
suzanne john hayes qui est adjointe à la
chair à poissy il n'y a pas de paris
saint germain semble département il n'y
a pas de tramway sans le paris saint
germain à carrières sous poissy n'y a
pas de tronc commun en site propre
s'il n'ya pas le département et à
achères n'y a pas de collège qui a pas
le département trois exemples sur
l'investissement et je dirais le
vraiment le partenaire privilégié
département et les élections
départementales sur le troisième tour de
l'élection municipale et il ya des
critiques notamment sur la personne de
pierre bédier j'imagine que vous lisez
ça notamment dans la presse de ses
opposants vrai qu'on écoute aussi yves
handball qui est conseiller
départemental aujourd'hui qui est
opposant enfin critique de l'action de
pierre bédier et qui fait partie de
votre majorité qui ne se représente pas
jouer que vous l'écoutiez on l'a reçue
ici à deux semaines ce qui me dérange
clairement c'est là c'est la façon de
conduire la politique du département
c'est un mode de fonctionnement je
dirais monarchique qui ne me convient
absolument pas et qui me paraît
d'ailleurs d'une autre époque
ce qui veut dire qu'en gros pierre
bédier décide de tout c'est exact c'est
exact de façon discrétionnaire c'est le
bon plaisir du roi on disait jadis vous
avez vous devez entendre ces critiques
notamment des des opposants de pierre
bédier localement à mantes la jolie
comment vous réagissez à cela pas bien
par rapport à ce que dit il van de waal
keita et keita partenaires que je
respecte beaucoup et qui connaît bien
plus ancien conseiller à ce que les
dirigeants lyonnais qui connaît bien
bien la politique dit il en connaît tous
ses codes
yves s'étaient engagés à un moment donné
a acquitté le conseil départemental
lorsque l'inde est l'un des siens
prendrait le relais
il l'a pas fait moi j'ai pris le relais
de livres de valdes sur un plan haut
débit pour l'ensemble des des
administrés j'ai modestement réussi dans
une autre voie que celle que préconisait
yves vandewalle en faisant des millions
d'économies monde est critiquable en jeu
c'est ce que voulait dire
abbas ne vous faites pas de votre pâte
politique je pense très honnêtement
quand on a vécu ce qu'a pu vivre
yves comme qui est vraiment un collègue
que je respecte comme d'autres collègues
et qu'on voit comment aujourd'hui se
porte le conseil départemental
moi je préfère regarder la lune que
d'autres montrent qu'en d'autres
montrent le doigt aujourd'hui karl olive
même si vous n'êtes pas engagé
politiquement dans un parti est ce que
vous êtes plutôt proche de l air ou de
la république en marche
moi je suis plutôt proche de la france
qui gagne c'est aussi des indications
non annoncés absolument pas de la
communication sinon je serais heller où
je serai en marche moi je considère
qu'aujourd'hui avec général on essaie
que ben on est au delà des des partis
politiques et des du dogmatisme pardon
de dire que quand dans nos quartiers ont
des doubles des classes entre cp et ce1
et c'est une idée du ministrère du
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer jean michel blanc clair
c'est une très belle idée et je le dis
et j'applaudis des deux mains
mais quand de l'autre je vois qu'à
poissy on a une perte cumulée de 28
millions d'euros en six ans en dotation
globale de fonctionnement alors que je
fais 25% d'économies ce qui me permet de
ne pas augmenter les impôts et que cette
enveloppe continue de baisser
je dis que monsieur macron devrait être
encore plus proche des des mers parce
que ça c'est une erreur qui peut ne pas
pardonner
dernière question car le livre sur un
sujet que vous affectionnez beaucoup le
paris saint-germain son centre
d'entraînement va arriver à possible ici
quelques quelques mois quelques années
je ne connais pas la date précisément
mais bon c'est pour bientôt
ce que le pg a des choses de se
qualifier mardi en match retour face à
manchester city ce qu'ils ont perdu le
match aller à l'eau rouge avenue
supporters alors aujourd'hui dimanche je
dis toujours que le paris saint germain
à poissy ses 1000 emplois pendant la
durée des travaux c'est 250 millions
d'euros c'est tout simplement
exceptionnel et jeudi le passionné qui
est là que encore une fois un peu comme
poser les élections tant que l'arbitré
n'a pas donné le coup de sifflet final
la partie est loin d'être loin d'être
joué il peut y avoir des surprises mon
petit doigt me dit que la coupe aux
grandes oreilles n'est pas loin pour le
paris saint-germain
eh bien on verra bien merci beaucoup
karl olive d'avoir participé à cet hebdo
politique sur radio sensations en
partenariat avec tv sont dit je rappelle
que vous êtes le maire de poissy vice
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines merci encore l hebdo politique
c'est fini pour ce dimanche vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission podcast audio
et vidéo sur les sites internet
applications réseaux sociaux de radio
sensations et tv 78 bonne soirée à tous
et à dimanche prochain pour un nouvel
hebdo politique
l'hebdo politique
[Musique]